concord
the name recalls a distant era when air
travel was more like this
welcome aboard the spacious cabin than
this
this guy's crazy almost two decades
after the concorde's last supersonic
leap across the ocean
concord nostalgia suddenly seems in full
swing
all chairs will have tray tables not
just first
class i feel like i'm flying on the
concord
you can leave any time meanwhile a new
generation of companies is promising to
bring supersonic jets back to an airport
near you
by as soon as the end of this decade but
can any of these companies successfully
pick up where the failed concorde left
off
[Music]
so the concord operated in the north
atlantic
it was primarily paris and london to new
york and washington
and we're now single sonic that's uh 11
minutes after
so it was exciting flying supersonic and
it's always exciting to get to new york
before you've left
there was a large measure of style and
panache and it wasn't like the world's
most comfortable cabin or seat compared
to what you would get on a private jet
today
but it was also the bragging rights of
how fast you could
you could do a day trip if you wanted
concord has crossed the atlantic in
three and a half hours
first best and fastest
it just never became a product for the
masses and
you know part of that was just the fuel
cusp these engines were
engineering marvels but at the same time
just completely fuel and efficient in
terms of what they had to do
after nearly three decades in service
the concord was retired in 2003
due to rising costs weakening demand for
air travel after 9 11
and a dampened safety reputation
following a fatal crash in 2000.
once at the bleeding edge of aviation
technology the legendary plane for the
elite had become a relic
destined for museums and exhibitions
today whether you're paying to ride back
here or
up here you'll arrive at about the same
time and that's because aircraft
manufacturers and
airlines have spent the past half
century focusing on things like
efficiency
safety and cabin comforts rather than
raw speed
but after almost two decades since
concord's demise
speed may be making a comeback there
is venture capital money and investors
that are willing to
bet that this could work secondly
there's technology available today that
was never
ever contemplated in the 1960s you can
model so many things with computers
and the new materials carbon composites
all those things are coming together so
that you have some
technically minded people saying why
shouldn't this happen
when concours shut down about 20 years
ago there was really no plan to pick up
where it left off
and so that's what we're doing at boom
we're building uh high speed travel that
can be available to more people than
ever before
boom is just one of a number of young
companies that have snatched up the
brightest aerospace
engineers for the task of designing a
new generation of supersonic aircraft
every airplane looks good on paper but
when you go from a paper design
to a physical airplane that you're going
to put a human life in
and then go fly you have to solve
thousands of problems along the way
but it's not inventing new science and
it's not inventing new technology
boom has been developing an experimental
supersonic jet called the xb1
which if successful will be the first
independently developed supersonic jet
ever with a name that harkens back to
the original supersonic jet the x1
the xb1 will be used to test and refine
the engineering
that will ultimately lead to a 100-seat
jet called overture that's more like a
concord
2.0 and if all goes well we'll be
carrying our first passengers by the end
of the decade
but building a commercial plane that can
break the sound barrier is old news at
this point
[Music]
i think google could probably go build a
supersonic business jet
in pretty short order if they wanted to
one not to sell it but just to do it you
know it's just got to be an economical
product you can't just do it as a vanity
thing
the first commercial supersonic
experiments in the 1960s were
essentially that
vanity projects the jointly built
british and french jet
literally a concord between nations and
rival prototypes from the soviets and
the americans were developed during the
same cold war technology race
that landed humans on the moon national
prestige outweighed concerns about
profitability
at least for a little while what about
the potential market for concord what's
the
lowest that could be sold and perhaps
the highest if we sold
50 or less i should be a very
disappointed man
disappointed indeed though it started
out with over 100 pre-orders
the jets problematic economics quickly
brought that number down to just 14
delivered to the national airlines of
the countries that built it
but the next generation of supersonics
are being designed mostly by private
companies where
market viability isn't merely an
afterthought it's paramount
so since concord retired at 03 there's
been a two and a half fold increase in
international travel
and that creates a lot more markets for
supersonic
and when you put together all the new
technology aerodynamics materials
propulsion
you can now build an aircraft that's
significantly more efficient than
concord
which means it can be available to tens
of millions of people it fares kind of
like what you'd pay in business class
today
instead of the the forex first class
that had to be charged on concord
so far boom's bold aspirations have
already caught the attention of a
handful of airlines
that have placed small pre-orders for
the company's overture jet
but whether these early votes of
confidence will translate into success
depends on the final economics
[Music]
another eager startup taking a different
approach to the new supersonic race
is spike aerospace which is developing
the s-512
an 18-passenger aircraft targeted at the
nearly 30 billion dollar private
business jet market
like boom though one of spike's
long-term goals is to eventually expand
supersonic travel beyond the realm of
elite luxury
we'd look back to the 90s when they
first had flat screen tvs
there were twenty five thousand dollars
at screen nobody could afford it
you know joe public couldn't afford it
it's only for the super rich
but now flat screens tvs are all two
hundred dollars and the same thing's
gonna happen in supersonic flight
yes initially it probably will be for
business travelers and the rich
folks and there is a demand they have a
need they can afford to fly it
as we recover cost and research and
development and technologies
we'll be able to offer that same
supersonic flight service to the general
public i don't know that'll be as cheap
as economy flights but it'll be
affordable or more affordable than it
will be
initially before these next generation
supersonics can make it to market though
there are other dark legacies of concord
that could divert a supersonic comeback
the first is simply too loud to ignore
what did you think about it oh man you
jump you made your jump
yes you're frightened of it at all no
not no no exactly what did you think of
it
rather slow one i thought
the deafening takeoff noise and infamous
sonic booms of supersonic aircraft
crossing the sound barrier
were so disruptive that it led to
widespread backlash and protests in the
1960s
eventually forcing governments to ban
all supersonic flight over land
but there's a potential solution taking
shape that could address both the
physics
and the regulation dilemmas of the sonic
boom
x59 is really a culmination of decades
of work by nasa to try
and solve the sonic boom problem
essentially to find a way to reduce
sonic boom such that it's
not not a boom anymore but a sound that
might be acceptable
if heard every day to accomplish that
goal nasa has partnered with lockheed
martin's famous skunk works division
to develop an advanced airframe design
that can actually minimize the impact of
the sonic shockwave on the ground
but the heart of the project is about
gauging public reaction
in order to pave the way for new
supersonic federal and international
guidelines
our plan is to do essentially five to
six
tests in various locations in the united
states
so hopefully get on the order you know
thousands of survey responses
you know given a sound of a certain
level this percentage of the population
is annoyed so it's all about providing
data
that can help the faa and the iko
establish the limits that go along with
this certification standard
producing or eliminating the nuisance of
sonic booms
could open up countless new routes
helping to make an economy of scale for
supersonic travel that was never
possible for concord
but there's another drawback of
supersonic flight that has taken on a
new importance over the past few decades
fuel consumption and emissions in order
to propel its 100-seat cabin to speeds
of nearly 1400 miles per hour
concord burned multiple times the amount
of fuel per passenger
versus a typical transoceanic jet given
the fluctuating cost of fuel
and the growing concern over the
environmental impacts of air travel
it's hard to imagine a modern carrier
purchasing planes as thirsty
and messy as the concorde once was but
recent technological strides may give
the supersonic startups a chance to
rectify
this negative legacy as well speed is
not enough we need to do it in an
environmentally responsible way and so
the question really for
us was can we engineer these liquid
fuels instead of just relying on
fossil-based fuels that are obviously
bad for our environment arion has
partnered with canada-based carbon
engineering
whose direct air capture technology
pulls co2 right out of the air
which can then be processed into
commercial products like jet fuel
it's still a bit theoretical at this
point but it would mean essentially
carbon neutral high speed flight
so think about the only co2 that the as2
arion's airplane puts into the
atmosphere
was first co2 we took out of the air to
make the fuel
so not only do we go really really fast
but we have
no footprint on the environment
well all of these supersonic startups
are eager for us to break the sound
barrier again
it's hard not to be at least a little
bit skeptical of the projections
given how notoriously difficult aircraft
development can be
for instance boeing's widebody 787
dreamliner reportedly ran billions of
dollars over budget and arrived to
market three years later than expected
and that's for a jet based largely on
proven subsonic technology
and well-proven subsonic economics
there's also the unknown long-term
impact on demand in a post-pandemic
world
in which business or vip travel may be
replaced more often by a virtual meeting
instead
then again supersonic might actually
offer extra appeal for travelers trying
to cut down on the time spent
in an enclosed cabin with a bunch of
other people the customer wants a
hundred things
i think that's where like the rubber
hits the road or whatever the cliche is
you know that's where you're gonna see
it's like can you
not not can you build this plane but can
you do it within all these parameters
that the market is
is setting for you another way to look
at the new supersonic race is that it's
part of a broader vision for a future
with
simply more options for long distance
travel whether by supersonic
hypersonic or an entirely new mode like
suborbital flights that hop between
points on the globe
this latest round of startups are simply
pushing us toward that frontier
[Music]
and that might sound a little pie in the
sky but when you're trying to usher in a
new age of super fast travel
it helps to be optimistic we're gonna go
across the atlantic and come home the
same day
we're gonna have more meetings in person
it's gonna change who you can fall in
love with you know i want a world where
no relationship is ever considered long
distance
you know that's not science fiction
you